there's something gained in something
lost in this remote work what's gained
is you stay home lower tax bases lower
cost of living be able to hire everybody
from anywhere so much to gain from it
mm-hmm what's lost so I think the you
know I think the creative sessions are
much harder to have so when I'm working
with early-stage founders on specific
tactics or the ways that their product
might look or feel or interact with
users I find that those sessions are
hard to replicate it may be impossible
to replicate to the same efficiency as
being in person
I think the serendipity of feeling
connected to your team you know you just
lose I don't think you know for pm5p and
zoom meetings they do something they
don't solve that that missing of the
human element I think it's harder to
have a separation between your work life
and your family life I realized that
that drive to the office for me and that
drive back from the office meet was
actually important time to separate my
work yeah my you know Wallisch a lot I
lost that moment which is interesting
so at like 30 minutes it was 30 minutes
in a good day it could be 45 on another
day but I mean it's like it's when I
called my mom and my dad and casual
checkup and it was a win down from the
intensity of the day so when I walked
into the house I was really ready to
receive my family and be more present
that moment that's the thing I'm kind of
missing is that 20 30 minute commute
really got me geared up for the day
putting that mindset I would do a phone
call listen to a podcast and yeah you
know really get in that mind and then it
would also yeah would it would be my
slow you know way to come down off of a
busy day and I do find now it's like
with my daughter's coming into the
office while I'm doing a podcast while
I'm on a zoom and everybody's fine with
it now it's just like alexis was on the
podcast his daughter was you know
jumping on his lap during the podcast
and I was like fantastic like yep yeah
I'm like it's making it yeah it's kind
of getting whatever a little the
pretense I was looking at my suits and
my Blazers today and I was like what do
I do with these yeah I agree
like I don't know why boy John it's very
comfortable like these are uncomfortable
decisions right like I'm looking at
these then your custom suits and I'm
like what's the point of
what am i doing these are for Halloween
now yeah I mean I don't know how to you
I mean yeah it is I I wonder if Facebook
or uber or Twitter any company that hit
massive scale mm-hmm
could hit massive scale being work from
home what do I wonder that too
I don't know you know I because it's
there's one thing to talk about money
and investing there's nothing to talk
about power like creating entities of
power that have influence of American
public or influence over individuals and
a lot of thought that powers gen is you
know created and magnified in person to
those in-person interactions I don't
know but I suspect we will see one I
mean certainly there'll be at least one
great giant company to come out of this
pandemic there might be multiple one of
them will be a big voice one of them
will be a big platform I don't know
which one it is if that's what I'm
trying to figure out is if remote I my
thesis is I don't think a company can
hit the the mega scale of Amazon
Microsoft Google Facebook ooh BRR by
being remote I think there's going to be
a cap to what can be accomplished and
I'll put that cap at you know five 10
billion
something's you're modest mm-hm you know
by our industry standards not modest by
success Briony means I mean right that's
right you and I never built a five
billion dollar company sure exactly
somebody builds a a billion dollar I
mean I think the only billion dollar
company that's ever been built remote is
WordPress probably Tran the cynical take
on that would be well maybe be a ten
billion dollar company if they were in
person maybe maybe I don't know that
that's the case but you also have to go
with you we have to live the lifestyle
and do what you want to build so this is
also given people you know something to
think about in that regard so yeah maybe
you don't have this transition time we
talked about mm-hmm but maybe it's kind
of cool that if you know your kid is
struggling with a math problem you could
stop the day I had to stop the day the
other day yeah I just said cancel the
next two meetings yeah I have to take my
daughter out she was struggling with
something and yep I wanted to work on
her with her for school and I literally
just cancelled the next two meetings and
my wife looked at me and she was like
but what and I said yeah yeah I just I'm
the CEO like it yeah texting my sister
cancelled next two meetings I'm taking
care of this it's more important because
I saw it
you know wasn't at me when I was at my
office I couldn't come home I'm not
coming home I mean if somebody gets
taken to the emergency room I'm leaving
work but if somebody's having a problem
with math or something and they're
struggling and it's frustrating I'm not
coming home from the office I'll deal
with that when I get home at six well
you also wonder like what if you took I
don't know the ages of your kids but you
know what everyone you tenant for right
and ten-year-olds almost there but
imagine your kids 12 and you said like
look two hours a day you're gonna shadow
me yes I would bet they would learn more
two hours a day shadowing you at age
twelve and beyond then they will through
their classes right you are 100 player
than better for their future careers
select their future careers bring them
into the work world in a more effective
way and I kind of wondered that like
there used to be the old thesis of
apprenticeship and mentorship and the
family business and suddenly I wondered
like it's not even a possibility but I
you know I love that I'm looking for
startups in that specific space we've
had two of them now Paragon ones in our
accelerator right now and we had one
previously that was trying to make it
work and it didn't work but I think
apprenticeship and I think paid
apprenticeship because you know
internships can't be free anymore
because you're abusing people or
whatever the nonsense was right I don't
know if you ever saw that story look at
New York Times story about this guy's
like I've been an intern for 15 years in
Hollywood and I and I still don't get
hired and I'm like I think that has to
do with you
yeah that's it's not an industry problem
that's right I think that's a you
problem if you've been working for a
decade or more yeah doing internships I
don't think you're being abused I think
you're abusing yourself or you just
maybe suck at your job now you can't
have unpaid internships anymore which
means why would you have an intern the
interns just a drag on productivity
that's right yep that's right whole
cecile was you're doing this for free
and therefore will deal with the drag
you are on productivity yep but I love
the idea of can you what would somebody
pay to have a slot next to a venture
capitalist for they're 16 to 20 year old
yeah per year yeah what is that worth
compared to $50,000 a year in college I
agree it's got to be worth more they
have to work at a venture for now that
does create the issue we're talking
about of class yep that's problematic
well I mean you don't have to charge for
it I mean the reality is that like
you know yes it's similar to internships
and maybe to avoid taxation you need
some sort are to invoice some other
structure around it but certainly I
think that from my kid's perspective the
time I spending them now evaluate to the
public markets making investments
reviewing pitch tax which is something
that we can serendipitously do because
I'm here and they're here and we can
look at things together you know I
believe that this will help you know
help them select their career in a
better way than probably some of their
classes you know I'm announcing right
now we're gonna have three
apprenticeships one's gonna be thirty
thousand one's gonna be ten thousand and
that one's gonna be free and so I'll
give one based on merit one will be
discounted and one will be full five so
if you if your kid is if you got a kid
who wants to be an investor they want to
learn this that's what it cost free up
tenant hi joked about it before
previously on Twitter because I do think
parents have to think this through what
it what amount of work do you think kids
are actually doing on academics at
school per day in the seven hour day now
that you have them at home we've looked
at this a lot and and we keep looking at
the homeschooling sector we liked it
before kovat we obviously like it a lot
after co vid but it schools are super
different one thing we found is there
are certain schools that are just like
slotting those zoom meetings for six
straight hours a day and there's other
schools where there's no connectivity
beyond every other day and kids are
self-managed and the other thing that I
assume that you hear and maybe you've
seen in your own life is that parents
with kids that are you know 11 year old
10 year old plus those kids can often
self manage like my 11 year old and my
and my 15 year old they you know they
they just run their days right like I'm
happy to be here in help but you know
when I talk to my you know my partners
and my staff and if they have young kids
they have a very different work at home
experience right like very difficult
right daddy come swim montre and summers
good night brutal right so I talked to
somebody today who has two young kids
and they're like all of our summer camps
are canceled canceled all of our
activities are canceled I don't want my
kid on the computer seven hours a day
like what do I do because I do need to
work I'm the primary breadwinner right
and so I think everyone's having a very
different experience through this this
quarantine